foreign
[Music]
so I just wanted to thank everyone for
joining us today
um it's really awesome to be back again
in person at least for me it's been a
lot of fun seeing everyone and uh being
in person for conferences again you know
TSA lines are back and jet lag is back
and all that good stuff but today we
have a really fun session for you we're
going to be talking about Google
kubernetes engine and why it should be
your Enterprise compute platform of the
future
um my name is Victor Salve I'm a product
manager I work on
Google kubernetes engine or I'm going to
be calling it just gke going forward I'm
joined by some colleagues uh to my to my
right here Sean Darrington
Sean is the group product manager
outbound product manager for the storage
space
and we're really excited to be joined
today by jumpy Nakajima from Capcom who
flew all the way here from Japan
so jump jump eight will be speaking
today in Japanese and he's joined by a
translator Mika at the end all right
so containers and kubernetes right have
really been taking the world of
infrastructure by storm
um it's been providing uh on-demand
scalability efficient resource
utilization for a range of applications
from of course your modern apps which I
think most of us associate containers
and kubernetes with
but that's been expanding and it's been
extending to things like batch and of
course you've been hearing about AIML
of course games
and even things like Legacy Enterprise
applications are now being run in
containers uh in kubernetes Google open
source kubernetes back in 2014. and in
doing so
we basically built the world's largest
ecosystem around containers
and if you think of containers then as a
specification or a standard for running
containers
um this means that your workloads are
highly portable
but in addition to the portability
element it's also created a uh an
ecosystem a huge community of Open
Source and and Commercial vendors that
are building and greatly expanding the
value proposition of kubernetes
so today Google remains really strongly
committed to kubernetes we are by far
the largest contributor to open source
kubernetes
um and Beyond open source gke
really leads the pack as the most
automated and scalable managed
kubernetes platform on the planet
we support up to 15 000 nodes per
cluster and there are customers doing
things like virtual super super
computers in their clusters they're of
course also doing large-scale llm model
training and so forth
so why gke and it turns out that
do-it-yourself kubernetes is often
really challenging right in the form of
a high degree of expertise required
um it's also very labor intensive so
your day two operations the labor effort
required there is very very high
so what we're trying to do with gke is
Preserve the spec the open source spec
as much as we can
while providing additional management
capabilities to alleviate that burden
and manage it for you
right and so this is things like for
example
upgrade management right release new
releases of kubernetes come out so we
help with upgrade management we help
with things like automated backups which
Sean's going to talk about
automated node scaling and all of this
greatly reduces your day to operations
toil and gives you the control you need
to be able to run your business the way
you want to run it
security is another aspect of kubernetes
that we really lean into right so out of
the box
we bring uh a baseline foundational
kubernetes security posture
and best practices alerting all of that
comes out of the box
in fact we work at every layer of the
stack from things like Hardware of
course to the virtualization tier to
things like OS we built a custom OS for
running containers effectively and
safely
and of course kubernetes itself to
provide that comprehensive security
posture
I think when most people think of
kubernetes they think of scale right and
of course
um kubernetes and gke scales to meet the
dynamic needs of your business and at
the time for that workload so that
alleviates a lot of the work having to
do with manually scaling up and manually
scaling down instead you can
automatically have gke provision your
infrastructure on demand and then watch
it scale down when it's not needed
and all of this comes with the
reliability you'd expect from a company
as committed to Containers as as Google
is so I don't know if you all know this
but almost everything at Google runs on
containers so including search Gmail
YouTube and so forth all of those
Services all run on containers and we've
been running containers for a very very
long time
and so it's not just the technology but
it's also our Engineers our SRE teams
and so forth we're a completely
container first organization that
provides us with a tremendous Advantage
uh when it comes to actually operating
and running gke as a cloud service
now in addition to the cluster level
capabilities that I've just talked about
you probably heard that this week we
announced gke Enterprise Edition
and this is really exciting because
sure we have a lot of services around
the cluster but what about if you have
10 clusters 30 clusters 100 clusters
a thousand clusters it starts to become
very challenging to manage them at scale
so we've introduced additional
capabilities like fleets and teams which
allow you to Define scopes
and basically keep everything
synchronized across regions
and also consistent right
this is all packaged with security in a
well integrated format
okay so what can you do with gku right
there's of course modern applications
and I think everybody kind of again
thinks of that as the first thing hey
we're going to run some microservices
we're going to build something new let's
use kind of this sort of architecture
and containers and so forth but there's
actually a whole lot more to it than
that
gke is being used for a number of things
including stateful and Legacy folks are
running databases
in gke
and Sean's going to be talking about
this quite a bit but that's really
helped by the notion of automated
backups that will snapshot your
persistence layer
um
safe blue green deployments and an
extensive selection of storage Right
storage options and again Sean at the
toward the end of the presentation is
going to get into this in a much more
detail
and then of course you may have heard
that this year uh AIML is pretty big
right
um vertex AI is of course our
recommended managed solution for AIML
but it turns out gke is also an amazing
platform for AIML and that's because
it Blends ideally the ease of
provisioning of Hardware accelerators
like gpus and tpus
it Blends that with capabilities like
compact placement and highly efficient
utilization of resources resource
sharing GPU sharing and so forth
and this is often needed when you want
more control right such as if you're
training your own models and so forth
and in fact I mentioned this earlier
many of the largest llm models today are
being trained on gke
the last one I'll mention is games and
of course we're going to talk about
games in a lot more depth today
um from from for the gaming perspective
uh especially live service games
they're also thriving on gke and in
large part because of the elastic
scalability meaning the unpredictable
demand of when people are playing the
games
um coupled with the fact that it's
highly cost efficient
and we're able to reduce the management
overhead associated with managing all
that infrastructure
so let's dive into games a little bit
more I'm going the right direction here
so at Google Cloud we're actually
building a platform for live games
and this unifies performance
with Analytics
so we've identified three critical areas
for games
and we're going to talk Beyond gke a
little bit just to paint you kind of a
broader picture
and nakajima-san is going to be talking
about a specific implementation that
Capcom did of this particular stack
so starting with the game servers this
is the technology that brings together
players from all over the world into a
common real-time experience we've open
sourced the agones server which is a
game server and it runs really
brilliantly on gke and it scales very
well on GK
next up are databases Cloud spanner
tends to be that the the database of
choice there for its massive scale and
global global footprint
and then of course there's analytics you
want to know how your players are are uh
feeling about the game and feedback and
so forth so bigquery and vertex AI
combine really well there to allow
companies to understand that that
business Dynamic and what's happening
with the players right
so do we have do we have any gamers in
the audience I know there's got to be
some gamers
yeah okay awesome I remember playing uh
Street Fighter in the arcade when I was
a kid spending most of my allowance on
quarters into the arcade game
um so you've probably heard of Street
Fighter as well it's a massively popular
live game
um
and it runs on Google Cloud uh and and
it's including uh and that includes of
course gke for the compute layer so
please join me in welcoming Mr jumpei
Nakajima technology lead for capcom's
Blockbuster live game Street Fighter 6.
[Applause]
thank you
and so
there you go okay okay
um
[Music]
good afternoon my name is Nakashima and
I am from Capcom Japan excuse my
Japanese
um
so Street Fighter 6 is a global Service
offering and it is built on a
microservices architecture deployed on
gke
the services are interconnected through
grpc and their traffic is controlled by
the andos service mesh
database is
so the database is cloud spanner which
allows for massive scaling while
maintaining consistency
is
then after matching up players
the actual games are played peer-to-peer
between clients
[Music]
this is because fighting games have
strict latency requirement
s
[Music]
is this so this is the diagram showing
the network infrastructure configuration
for Street Fighter 6.
clusters are built in four main regions
U.S Central South America Europe and
Asia
um
[Music]
regardless of which region you are
accessing from HTTP requests are always
made to the same cluster
foreign
[Music]
what's important to note here is that
the access lines to the various gcp
Services only extend from the main
cluster which is U.S Central
that receives the HTTP requests foreign
ERS have grpc routes that lead to the
main cluster which is U.S Central
um
[Music]
so that no main clusters ask the main
cluster to process the data via GL PC
and the actual access and processing of
the data is only done by the main
cluster
is
let's take a closer look at the
multi-cluster mesh configuration
is
we have just explained the HTTP requests
are taken care of by the main cluster
built in U.S Central from any region
foreign
network is really aiding us
this way the path of data access can be
Unified
um
um sorry it's very small on this chart
but there's a little red line
um and this is lying is the only access
path to the various resources uh
basically it means that the um only the
main region would process the data and
that this line does not extend outside
of the main cluster
foreign
this way user data is not scattered
across the various regions and only
latency and latest and remains constant
no matter where it is accessed
um
okay
so this means that the data access is on
uh sorry
um so this way the user data is not
scattered across the various regions and
latency remains constant no matter where
is Success however you have websocket
access flying to each Region's cluster
and these uh the battle have service
servers on the street fighter 6 and and
basically this is a visual Lobby servers
foreign
ize the action of up to 100 players and
need to communicate with regions that
are physically close to each other due
to strict latency requirements foreign
however the the visual Lobby servers are
basically only
um
performing the action synchronization
communication and the data operation is
requested from the main cluster via glpc
s
this is also to prevent the scattering
of the data and unify the data access
route
so
[Music]
um
this access path which goes through glpc
is constructed by multi-cluster mesh of
anthos service mesh which goes through
gcp's internal line it doesn't go out to
the internet which actually allows for
much faster communication than using the
internet
thank you that is all for my
presentation that was the brief
explanation of the architecture thank
you very much
thank you nakajimasan for sharing your
experience and congratulations to you
and the team for Street Fighter 6. that
was fantastic
[Applause]
so you know as you heard Victor say
earlier you know kubernetes and gke has
been around for a long time and many
Enterprises have been deploying
stateless applications on gke and that's
perfectly fine to do however as more
companies are deploying stateful
applications some of the more
traditional Enterprise applications are
being migrated and deployed on gke and
that changes the way you have to think
about managing those Services because
things like backup now become important
there are other things around storage
that's also important but regarding
backup for gke this is something that we
launched last year at storage day and
next uh the virtual next last year and
that has been generally available for
over a year now
we're proud to be leading this and this
is now generally available as a fully
managed service for you to deploy and
protect your clusters and this is a
differentiator for Google Cloud as you
look at the different reasons and the
capabilities of being able to now
protect cluster configurations in a very
automatic and consistent way it gives
you a very granular option to deploy
backup for gke to protect the cluster
configuration your namespaces of choice
application consistent backups and or
data that's used by gke so if you have
persistent data that needs backing up
this is a fully managed service that you
can take advantage of it's one of the
things that allows not only the recovery
of the data in the event of data
corruption or human error but one of the
things that a lot of our customers are
using this for more so than protecting
the data itself is actually the cluster
configurations and that gives you as
developers in devops the opportunity for
very easy and consistent rollbacks for
errors that happen
unfortunately very very frequently right
so as you're upgrading the Clusters if
that happens you have a run into a
problem you can roll back that cluster
configuration very seamlessly you also
have the opportunity most gka clusters
use persistent disk or block storage
others use file systems and I'll talk to
that in just a moment but backup for gke
also gives you that opportunity to use
and protect the data stored on
persistent disk it gives you this
flexibility to store and protect the
cluster configuration and storage in a
specific and retention lock period so
what this means is for a given backup
policy you can Define what cluster
configuration you want to protect the
data and you can set a specific period
of time that that backup is immutable
and indelible so you can set it for days
weeks or years if need be and what that
means is that whether it be human error
or ransomware that compromises and tries
to compromise your data that backup is
secure you as an admin and even as a
super admin privilege cannot change the
backup policy you cannot delete that
backup nor can you even delete the
entire project that that backup is
protecting once that retention lock
until that retention lock period
actually expires
so it's a great thing to protect that
backup for that retention lock period
but also from an Administration
standpoint if you set it for a year and
you want to change that period to three
months you now have nine more months to
wait until that one year expires so take
that into account as you're setting
those retention lock periods but this is
also one of the things that allows you a
lot of flexibility to protect those
resources and data as I described at a
very granular level and recover clusters
in the same region either to the new or
existing cluster or as a migration
opportunity if you're moving from U.S
Central One To Us East four you can use
this backup and recovery process to
actually recover and create new clusters
in different regions very seamlessly
with the exact same
configurations that you use in the
original one
so very flexible to do but as I
mentioned earlier this is one of the
things that's a little bit surprising in
that customers use backend for gke to
protect the cluster configuration as a
larger percentage is actually protecting
the data itself so you can use it in a
variety of ways cyber Haven will be
talking in a session around backup
recovery how they're able to actually
recover their data 24 times faster with
backup for gke they have the confidence
in their devops process and for
regulatory purposes the backup Vault and
that retention lock period that I was
describing is one of the things that
helps them satisfy their compliance
requirements so you can hear more from
cyber Haven in that session as well
storage is one of those things that a
lot of times has been an afterthought
for GK or just deploy persistent disk
and you're done however you heard this
morning from Thomas and Sundar that 70
of the unicorns today are using gke
right and are using Google cloud in
general and a lot of those training
models actually require or prefer file
system access for training they can't be
refactored either from a cost or a Time
standpoint they can't be refactored to
use object storage or maybe it's a
latency requirement and if you don't use
file systems now you avoid having cat
data cached locally in the pods and
clusters but you also have idle GPU and
TPU Cycles waiting while you're
extracting from object storage loading
into the into the containers and then
beginning the training so there are a
few options you can look at one is in a
passive storage the other is posix right
these are full file system semantics
access multi-writer use cases you also
have the option for fuse which has been
open source for over 10 years that you
can use with object storage and that
gives you essentially the way a file
system access to a bucket right and in
all three of these scenarios whether it
be fuse posix or NFS it's all maximizing
your GPU and TPU Cycles because it's a
file system it's immediately available
for training and so what we announced
last week and is generally available now
is cloud storage views this is a fully
managed fuse offering that you can use
from Google Cloud it's also free of
charge but you can now Mount Your
buckets like they were a file system it
provides that file system semantics but
it's not full posix compliance so there
are some caveats like multi-writer
support and things like that but you
have the ability now to have your
massive Scale Models petabytes Etc
immediately mounted to gke through the
CSI driver use your pytorch and
tensorflow workflows to do this and it
provides massive scalability and massive
performance we have customers today
exceeding 30 terabytes per second of
throughput with cloud storage and their
training
not everybody's going to be at that
scale and that's perfectly fine but it
is one of the things that now gives you
more opportunity to deploy a fully
managed service in the packages that we
actually provide we have a number of
images that you can use or you can do it
yourself as well
the other thing that we announced last
week was for file systems and in this
case training models that need ultra
high performance and multi-writer
support and that's where we introduced
parallel store this is currently in
preview this is another new and newly
introduced Google managed service it's a
parallel file system so now it's
actually built on Intel deus's open
source
cloud-based deployment model it's a key
value store so it's very Cloud friendly
in terms of massive scale in terms of
the number of nodes capacity Etc that
you can do but it's one of the things
that actually maximizes the gpus and
tpus as well because every pod and
cluster has equal access to the data it
supports full posix and it's a parallel
file system but it's also ultra high
performing and provides ultra low
latency so in this case you can see that
we're 6.3 times faster than other
scratch luster deployments and we
actually can exceed terabytes per second
of throughput with millions of iops and
0.3 milliseconds latency okay very
different contrast to cloud storage
different purpose but it's another
option for a given training knowledge
you have we have also integrated a
rational coding in the back end to
protect that data from if a node goes
down in in or data volume goes Offline
that persistent volume is actually
protected via Erasure coding
so these are two of the options that
we've recently introduced cloud storage
fuses GA parallel store is in preview
and file store is a third option for NFS
for gke there are two different file
store options file store Enterprise
actually three I should say file store
basic file store Enterprise and file
store High scale they each have
different features and functions I'm not
going to go into all the details in this
session here but these provide the
option to use different performance
levels capacity levels availability and
pricing for gke
file store Enterprise we've recently
enhanced the multi-share capability for
those that are using files for
Enterprise multi-share you've been used
to this at 100 Gig persistent volume you
can now get down to 10 gig capacity per
persistent volume so again it's an NFS
share it's available to hundreds or
thousands of pods in a given cluster it
has multi-writer support so every pod
knows exactly what file they're opening
and closing and writing and you're not
going to compromise your data from that
perspective so it's a great way to have
a scalable way for not only the data to
be accessible across all pods but if
pods go down the other pods still have
access to the exact same data and your
applications just continue to run
I mentioned the differences in files
store between basic Enterprise and high
scale Enterprise has a 49 SLA associated
with it which means that it actually
deploys and the storage in three zones
within a region and synchronously
replicates every single right across all
three zones in a given region so now
you're protected from a zono outage and
if your architecture is such that you
want to do the compact placement that
Victor was talking about in different
zones within a region you can also match
that availability with the storage of
file store Enterprise
backup for gke I described how that can
protect data the persistent data that
you want in persistent disk as well as
hyperdisc but just the block storage and
persistent disk that will also support
file store in the near future
in the meantime what we have coming next
quarter is the ability to just use file
store basic a file store backups to
protect either the entire instance or
multiple shares if you're using the 10
gig persistent volumes you can have that
level of granularity two different ways
to protect the file store data based
upon the file store to you that you're
deploying and that'll be available next
quarter
shortly after that we'll be supporting
backup for gke so you can use the backup
vault in the retention lock in the same
granularity and policy based protection
in the meantime you have another way to
protect the data until backup for gke
supports file store
so we've been expanding our file
offerings not only for AI and ml but
obviously for other HPC workloads and
other General compute workloads but this
is a way you can kind of think about
your training model needs whether it be
text or video and image and it's not a
one-size-fits all right you can choose
the right storage for different models
and pick and choose on the far left you
have the option for ultra low latency
very high iops file sizes that are in
the kilobytes or tens of megabytes or
even you know 50 megabyte range that's
great for parallel store it's a great
solution for a parallel file system
maybe also file store where maybe you
don't need the terabyte terabytes per
second you don't need that massive scale
you can choose something in the middle
and on the far right when you look at
cloud storage you can choose this now
with fuse as a file system interface for
your training model needs but it gives
you that still very high throughput
lower latency because it's regardless of
the storage bucket you're using the
storage class it's still milliseconds of
response times or maybe tens or hundreds
of milliseconds whether it be standard
or all the way down to the archive
storage class with cloud storage you're
still talking milliseconds it's not
minutes to hours to days as some other
Solutions have right so you now you have
a Continuum of options for file system
access across parallel file systems
posix NFS and object storage to choose
from across your portfolio
I mentioned cyber Haven in um Arc 200 is
a session there if you look at ARC 208
these are some other sessions of
Interest Arc 208 is going to be talking
about cloud storage and fuse in more
detail and codeway is going to be
co-presenting their code way and for
those that aren't familiar have a
generative AI model for avatars they use
gke cloud storage fuse to do this and
they've been able to ramp up to millions
of users seamlessly so you can hear more
about codeway in that one
the
hyperdesk the persistent disk I
mentioned with GK Arc 219 ruin Hess is
going to be leading that with hyperdisc
is our next Generation block storage and
then a little more detail on file store
as well as net volumes and Arc 220 and
then lastly Arc 217 in the lower left
there for the high performance Computing
that will go into more details about
parallel store and some of the specific
testing metrics that we have there so
there'll be many more many more details
in those breakouts
lastly I wanted to ask everybody just
remind if you have a chance to fill out
the survey form it'd be great to get
your feedback for for that session so we
can always improve upon that and with
that I'd like to thank everybody for
attending
foreign